have you ever wondered when the absolute
best time to start your seeds are no
matter what gardening zone you live in I
had the exact same question it came from
my second year of gardening when I
planted most of my vegetables at the
wrong times because I didn't know this
gave me almost no Harvest I was
discouraged but I knew there had to be a
better way last December I spent 30 days
and going through over 60 websites
trying to design the best Garden
planning schedule that work for anyone
one no matter where you lived in this
video I'm going to show you the Zone 8
garden planting schedule in four easy
steps and how to use it as a secret
weapon that will evolve your gardening
skills before we get started if you are
interested in picking one of these
secret weapons up then check out the
pinned Link in the description so far I
have made them for zones 3 to 9 if you
live in one of those zones you're in
luck goal number one 35 of the world's
most popular for the first two years of
gardening I would actually go to the
nurseries to find out what I could plant
in my zone 4 if I saw something they
were selling then I knew I could plant
it in my garden but they didn't always
have everything in stock over the years
I kept the list and on the left of the
garden planting schedule I put 35 of the
world's most popular vegetables in
alphabetical order so anyone could find
what they looking for faster plus it
looks cooler goal number two seeing the
whole year I always felt overwhelmed and
found that the gardening season crept up
on me too fast never felt as prepared as
I should have been so I wanted to see
the whole year of gardening on this
planting schedule then you would at
least see how many months you have to
prepare for your next gardening season I
put in all 12 months on this calendar
and the white spots are the areas where
you can't grow anything most of the time
that'll be your winter and the weather
won't be right and you'll be able to
visualize how many months you have to
prepare for the next gardening season
goal number three protecting some plants
when it comes to cool season or warm
season crops they do vary with kale
it'll taste better with a a little Frost
but for tomatoes plants die right away
in Canada we have a long period of snow
and the weather can change quickly I
went through different forums websites
and took the average last than the first
expected Frost AES for each Zone just to
warn you it is an average even a few
miles away from where you live now could
have different weather so use these
Frost dates as a reference when it gets
closer to those Frost dates check your
local weather daily at the top I wrote
both Frost dates and made both different
colors putting them in the 12-month
planting schedule running them all the
way down so you can see it with each
vegetable goal number four when should
everything happen timing is everything
in your garden it just so happens if you
want to get a few Harvest out of certain
vegetables or to just get the most out
of your garden you have to plant things
at the proper times it's a pretty easy
thing to fix let me help you I added red
for when you should start your seeds
indoors yellow for when you should
transplant outdoors and green for direct
sewing and harvesting on the 12-month
calendar you will start sum your seeds
indoors
for example Tomatoes get started at the
beginning of February or within the red
then transplanted Outdoors at the
beginning of April after there is no
chance of frost and green you can start
harvesting your Tomatoes some vegetables
such as spinach can be direct sewed
before the last frost date with the
green but bell peppers with a red will
start indoors to get a head start and
Transplant it out in the yellow and then
any vegetables that has two sets of red
yellow and green means you can start
them indoors transplant them and harvest
them twice in a growing season
I also found rooted crops were really
hard to tell when they're ready to
harvest most of the final growth comes
quickly and underground I've let some
beets grow for too long and the flavor
and how hard they are changes quite a
bit you want to harvest most of your
vegetables at the proper time on the
right I took the average harvesting days
across many Seed Company websites and
Seed packages so you'll know around what
time you should Harvest so here it is
the final copy after a 50-day design the
idea behind the Zone garden planting
schedule was was that I wanted to find
out what I can plant in my zone and when
I can plant everything I designed it to
be a 24 in x 36 in poster size so you
can frame it and use it as a reference
anytime you want or even put it on your
wall in your grow room now that you know
the perfect garden planting schedule for
any Zone would you like to find out the
best seed starting setup that anyone can
build watch this video next to find out
how love you
[Music]
bye oh